das ist eine absolute sensation die
bausteine des lebens proteine sollen mit
einer speziellen technik in
außerirdische meteoriten aufgespürt
worden sein proteine sind höchst
komplexe moleküle die leben überhaupt
erst möglich machen und die soll es
draußen im weltall geben bot das wäre
tatsächlich die vorstufe zur
außerirdischem leben jetzt wird diese
entdeckung heißt diskutiert kriegs und
science in future hier gibt es drei mal
pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
ging's
herzlich willkommen das ist eines der
größten rätsel der menschheit überhaupt
wie und wann genau ist das erste leben
ja wie und wann sind überhaupt die
ersten lebenden zellen auf der erde
entstanden fest steht nur trotz
intensiver forschung haben wir dazu bis
heute immer noch keine eindeutige
antwort ist das leben etwa aus den
meeren entstanden in der nähe von heißen
quellen oder sind die grundlegenden
substanzen die es für die entstehung von
leben braucht sogar aus dem all auf die
erde gelangt es sind nicht wenige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
weltweit überzeugt davon sind dass unser
aller ursprung das weltall ist ein komet
oder einer suite könnte die bausteine
des lebens mit auf die erde gebracht
haben und genau diese these wird jetzt
durch einen spektakulären fund eines us
forschungsteams gestützt denn die
fachleute wollen jetzt auf drei
meteoriten eiweißmoleküle entdeckt haben
sollte sich das bewahrheiten wäre das
eine absolute sensation denn dass es
organische moleküle im tiefen kosmos
gibt ebenso wie aminosäuren das ist
längst bekannt der nachweis eines
proteins wäre also der nächste logische
schritt dennoch gibt es
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die an der neuen entdeckung zweifeln wie
genau wurden die bausteine des lebens in
den außerirdischen meteoriten aufgespürt
und können wir mit diesem sensationsfund
möglicherweise sogar das große rätsel
nach dem ursprung des lebens auf der
erde lösen die spannenden antworten auf
all diese fragen gibt es jetzt hier
wachstums 1 in future erst vor wenigen
monaten hatte ein spanisches
forschungsteam für aufregung sorgt die
rede ist von einer wirklich
spektakulären entdeckung denn damit
wurde die existenz von außerirdischen
leben von jetzt auf gleich sehr viel
wahrscheinlicher der spannende fund des
spanischen forschungsteams verstärkt
nämlich die hypothese dass die zutaten
für das leben aus dem all kommen denn
die fachleute haben in interstellaren
molekülwolken ein molekül nachgewiesen
dass als wichtiger baustein für die zell
bildung geht konkret handelt es sich
hierbei um den stoff woraus die
zellhülle gebildet werden kann diese
schirmt das innere der zelle vor der
außenwelt ab und schützt es vor
umwelteinflüssen heißt also im klartext
auch dieser entscheidende bestandteil
der ersten zellmembran könnte
ursprünglich aus dem weltall stammen und
somit wären alle drei grundlegenden
bestandteile die zellen brauchen bereits
im all nachgewiesen ein weiterer starker
hinweis also der für die sogenannte
punch perry spricht übersetzt heißt der
begriff so viel wie samen überall der
chemiker 20 arrhenius hatte die
sogenannte spann perry hypothese bereits
im jahr satz 8 begründet er hatte damals
postuliert dass sowohl staubkörner als
auch viren und bakterien mit wind und
wetter weit weg von der erde bis ins all
gelangen könnten so schlussfolgerte er
dann daraus dass das auch auf
umgekehrtem wege passieren könnte die
groben von fremden planeten könnten sich
auf die reise gemacht haben um die erde
zu besiedeln im klartext meint punch
perry also einen außerirdischen ursprung
des irdischen lebens von dieser
hypothese gibt es eine weitere abstufung
demnach stammt nicht das leben an sich
aus dem kosmos allerdings die zutaten
die für die entstehung von leben auf der
erde wichtig sind wissenschaftlich
belegt ist schon längst das sauerstoff
stickstoff wasserstoff und kohlenstoff
in großen mengen im weltraum vorkommen
kometen sind voll damit das wissen wir
seit 25 jahre 1986 hatten fachleute den
heimischen kometen genauer untersucht
und die analyse des kometen stopps
deckte auf dass je sogar ein einfacher
bau stand für proteine zu finden ist
glycin organisches material wurde dann
auch nochmal zwischen ice geröll und
staub des kometen zur ihm auf
gerasimenko nachgewiesen chemische
elemente also die für das leben
entscheiden sind und die scheint es
wirklich überall zu geben sogar in
jungen sternensystemen weit von der erde
entfernt auch dort haben astronomie
teams bereits komplexe organische
moleküle aufgespürt möglicherweise sind
diese bausteine des lebens und ihre
vorläufer also vor langer zeit auf die
erde gebastelt beim sogenannten großen
bombardement von rund vier milliarden
jahren schlugen möglicherweise also
zahlreiche meteoriten auf der erde ein
und genau das könnte damals den
grundstein für leben gelegt haben denn
auch in verschiedenen proben von
meteoriten konnten bereits aminosäuren
und nukleinsäuren nachgewiesen werden
doch die aktuelle entdeckung ist noch
mal absolut bahn brechen und sprengt
unsere bisherige vorstellungskraft denn
diesmal sollen es nicht nur aminosäuren
sein sondern vollständige eiweißmoleküle
das wäre eine echte premiere dazu sagt
einer der entdecker der physiker malcolm
mit georg dies ist das erste mal dass
wir ein vollständiges protein entdeckt
haben dass nichts von der erde stammt
und zwar nicht nur in einem meteoriten
sondern sogar gleich in drei methoden
zum einen der mit os 4 0 86 87 in
algerien entdeckt wurde außerdem allende
der 1969 in mexiko eingesammelt wurde
der schon 1857 in ungarn gefunden wurde
wann die methoden jeweils auf der erde
eingeschlagen sind ist dagegen unbekannt
dennoch haben sie offensichtlich eine
gemeinsamkeit das konnte die haver
zellbiologen juli mit georg herausfinden
weil sie die meteoriten mit der hilfe
einer anderen untersuchungsmethode als
üblich analysiert hatte dazu sagt sie in
der vergangenheit haben unsere kollegen
meteoriten 24 stunden lang aus gekocht
wenn sie untersucht und dabei wurden
mögliche makromoleküle natürlich
zerstört so findet man immer nur freie
aminosäuren die bausteine von proteinen
wir haben bei unseren untersuchungen
aber darauf geachtet dass die meteoriten
maximal zimmertemperatur ausgesetzt
waren und so
sind wir fündig geworden
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler hatten dafür von allen
methoden hauchdünne schnitte angefertigt
und diese dann mit einem
massenspektrometer untersucht das
ergebnis ist spektakulär denn alle drei
meteoriten enthalten intakte proteine
wenn man dieser analyse glauben mag
diese setzten sich vor allem aus einer
bestimmten aminosäure zusammen glycin
die medizin ketten sind über silizium
brücken angebunden lithium atome
eisenatome und sauerstoff atome befinden
sich am reaktiven ende der moleküle für
ein solches organisches molekül ist die
anwesenheit von eisen und lithium her
ungewöhnlich wie die fachleute
festhalten auch das verhältnis von
normalem wasserstoff deuterium also
schwerem wasserstoff spricht demnach
dafür dass dieses protein nicht von der
erde stammt und noch mal proteine sind
nicht irgendwelche moleküle sondern
hochkomplex und damit auch in der lage
ganz bestimmte aufgaben zum beispiel in
unserem körper zu übernehmen verglichen
mit einem normalen molekül das für das
leben notwendig ist kein einzelner
bausteine sondern ein taschenmesser des
lebens
dieses komplexe protein was die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
nun in den außerirdischen meteoriten
aufgespürt haben wollen soll helmut team
heißen so der namensvorschlag der
entdeckerin und entdecker doch woher
stammen die gesteinsbrocken die
fachleute haben hier den
asteroidengürtel zwischen mars und
jupiter im visier manchmal wird dieser
auch als eine art resterampe des
sonnensystems bezeichnet und das nicht
ohne grund hier findet sich allerlei
geröll das bei der entstehung der
planeten übrig geblieben ist das
forschungsteam geht also davon aus dass
sie analysierten meteoriten etwa so alt
sind wie auch der rest des sonnensystems
heißt also etwa so zwischen 4 und 5
milliarden jahren ganz anders allerdings
bei den chemischen elementen die jetzt
aufgespürt worden sind diese haben sich
schon wohl vor 12 bis 13 milliarden
jahren gebildet unmittelbar nach der
ersten generation von sternen doch was
genau ist dann passiert dazu die
zellbiologen juli mit georg viele
wissenschaftler glauben solche moleküle
könnten auf einen planeten treffen der
immer richtigen abstand um die sonne
kreist sowie die erde und dort eine
biochemische revolution in gang setzen
doch die entdeckung des ersten
außerirdischen protein sorgt für eine
hitzige debatte in der fachwelt von
vielen seiten gibt es zweifel handelt es
sich bei diesem makromoleküle überhaupt
um ein protein und zum anderen ist
dieses wirklich extraterrestrische zur
ersten frage dazu hat sich der chemiker
liegt grün ihn geäußert sie haben kein
protein gefunden ein protein ist nicht
nur eine ansammlung von atom es ist
etwas das durch den prozess der
evolution entstanden ist nehmen sie zum
beispiel hämoglobin das ist ein sehr
großes proteine in unserem blut es ist
für den sauerstofftransport
verantwortlich hämoglobin besteht aus
mehreren 100 aminosäuren die in einer
präzisen reihenfolge angeordnet sind bei
dem nun entdeckten molekül handelt es
sich demnach wenn überhaupt um ein
polymer in der fachsprache sind damit
verbindungen also makromoleküle gemeint
die aus sich wiederholenden einheiten
bestehen das angebliche außerirdische
protein aber habe ja keine funktion doch
genau das macht proteine aus dazu die
stellungnahme vom entdecker selbst
merken anfangs hatten wir keine idee
welche funktionen dieses protein haben
könnte sieht aus wie eine struktur aus
irgendetwas einer abgerüstet man könnte
es mit der entdeckung eines reduzierten
fossils vergleichen es ist ein
dreidimensionales gitter mit großen
zwischenrang wir glauben dass sich darin
material an sammeln könnte um sich
ständig zu vergrößern zur zweiten frage
handelt es sich um ein außerirdisches
molekül oder nicht darüber könnte der
sogenannte dresen aufschluss geben denn
die fachwelt geht davon aus dass sich
biologisch entstanden aminosäuren
ausschließlich links herum drehen
zumindest auf der erde wenn sie nicht
biologisch entstanden sind kommen sie
sowohl rechts als auch links drehen vor
dazu der us-wissenschaftler jeffrey
bader eine der goldenen regeln bei der
untersuchung von aminosäuren versagt
untersuche ihre links und rechts
händigkeit also wie herum sie sich
drehen sollten ihnen den drei meteoriten
also links und rechts trainer
zu gleichen teilen vorkommen wäre dies
ein beweis dafür dass sie außerirdischen
ursprungs sind diese analysen stehen
tatsächlich noch aus und so müssen wir
uns weiter gedulden bis dann final
feststeht ob es sich tatsächlich um das
erste außerirdische protein handelt sind
wir außerirdische da in diesem video
hier geht es um die entdeckung der
aminosäure des letzten bausteins für die
zellmembran also anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren geht mit jedem abo button
unter jedem video bis dann bleibt dran